i want to invite everybody to watch my
uh netflix special that will be
premiering on
netflix
platform
uh tuesday october 19th make sure to
thumb it up and do all the deals
share it let your friends know
you guys are always supportive so
just when you get some time check it out
and thank you if you ever came to see
that tour on the road and um
and if you didn't i'm glad you're
getting to see it and i love you
i remember when i first got with my lady
you know and and like she's she's
helping me pack to go on a road trip and
i'm putting my xbox in my little
carrying case with the monitors a game
system you know you know
i'm just that she probably said that no
no she was like
why are you taking your game she's gonna
realize i go like this well normally i
would chase hoes
and then she goes where's your
controller
[Music]
i'm that guy you know what i'll get you
in about two years you know what i was
the same way about breaking bad yeah me
too okay
so so so it took me like it was season
three it already started and i was like
okay let me check it out
oh man hooked i i caught up what's weird
is i don't learn because i was the same
way about game of thrones i was you
never watch
no it's my favorite show thank you i was
three years late on it because i was
like my joke was like rogan and brian
when we're on the show they're like dude
you're not watching game of thrones i
because they're dragons like yeah i'm
like dude i'm 35. oh you're i'm almost
done i was is it on some nerd [ __ ] is it
on some nurture no not at all but then
i started watching it god damn the
lineage
i was late to yellowstone you watch
yellowstone i haven't seen that what's
that about
hey there's too many shows like i can't
get into
all these relationships
shows are relationships yeah and i won't
cheat on one i have to finish it i gotta
be in and then i just can i give you a
little rule that i do for myself
if i dvr things right if four episodes
are in my dvr and i haven't watched i
know i'm not into it and i'd erase it
and i never watch it again there that's
all right that's my test there so if i
you know so if i let four episodes build
up and i haven't got to it i know it's
not it hit it didn't grab me and i moved
the hell on that's fair midnight mass
you're aware of midnight mass it's uh
it's
right
it can be
but dude you have to just you need
patience it's one of those slow kind of
burns see i don't mind that so dude once
you figure it out yeah you'll be like
holy because it's it's the same uh crew
that did the the house on the whatever
yeah
or something like that was great the
second yeah
can i reveal it or should i ruin it
the gin oh it's good you told me that
it's good right i liked it dude quality
movie you know why i liked it because
they didn't it was like a low like indie
filming 17 to shoot you didn't yeah you
didn't need a huge location you shot one
apartment
yeah no i haven't seen now okay yeah
yeah yeah that was cool stevie's podcast
has a bigger budget yeah for sure that's
not saying that's the same yeah right
this show
don't be nice about we got that titanic
it's all the hot plate is the biggest
thing on the budget
oh you know what i told steve to uh
bobby to watch steve white lotus
what's that about oh white lotus is one
of the best shots on netflix it's on
there you know what you should do no
it's on hbo you should be a movie
reviewer too that'd be good yeah you
know because we're from season by season
yeah like show by show i know you know
what i've been doing on my podcast now
riffing with griffin as i recap movies
like i tell the story of the movie from
beginning to end especially when it's
ridiculous so i just did
fast and furious 9 because i saw it on a
plane
that movie is the most ridiculous
nonsense i stopped watching after i
haven't seen one when they start when
they started like jumping the cars build
into buildings dude hanging out a
helicopter wait this one this one that's
all i say about this one tyrese
and ludacris
are in the 87 pontiac fiero in space
that's all i gotta say yeah i'm out good
thumbs down that's all i got so if you
want to receive a recap
but tyreese fully redeemed himself
because you see vin diesel post a
picture of him on a yacht and he has
like a gut and people were clowning them
and tyreese jumped in the comments
because one dude was like oh look at
your fat ass on the yabala and tyrus
goes bro you have a shirt and no yachts
wow
got it
yeah well he's got the dad pod
i don't know that's dad buddy look at
that tummy on me he's probably can the
guy live
he's worth like 900 million okay he can
do whatever he wants yeah he's good he's
a rich dude he'll give back to so he's
just well did the
uh
all those fast and furious is he he has
ownership in it yeah so he's the
executive producer
he's quietly becoming a billionaire
is it you need to be into cars no no
reason they in the jungle
and he's got like
a a charger
they're in the jungle and he has this
like you know like a ford mustang or
something driving in the jungle it's not
a good jungle choice
a vehicular jungle choice for a car and
i just go how does this car get here
like it's like you're looking too into a
dog that's all what these movies are
about can i tell you something i can't
turn it off that's my thing
me neither if i'm in a movie i'm like
hot like i'm questioning everything like
the the thing i don't understand about i
haven't seen like six seven eight okay
so i'm looking at nine and for some
reason like for some reason this started
off as a racing mechanic street racer in
east l.a now all of a sudden he's an
international spy when did that [ __ ]
happen
they just got you know
government got involved i can't i can't
like get past some of the stuff
i took my son to see venom too and oh
dude
i'm not a writer i've never directed a
movie but i i know damn well i can do
better than that i don't know if it's
because of covid or what but
tom hardy's a honk dude no he's a beast
he's a handsome dude he's in a great
show he's hella handsome he's good but
even my son was like this is poorly
released he's got a show on stars or
something i forgot what it's called but
it's like an old-timey show and it's
he's a great actor at least he's such a
great he's a lot i love him he's saying
but he already said uh on the venoms he
was like you know it's kind of a cop out
through these marvel movies he's like i
got the script my kid's like oh you're
doing mar or you're doing venom he's
like he's like i didn't know about it i
don't like the voice
i don't like venom's voice it's weird
yeah
taboo's on fx that's such a great show
yeah you've seen that too yeah i don't
know how do you have time to watch all
these are you busy yeah about nightstand
you just binge stuff you know i'm on the
road in a hotel you're on the road you
choose so you so as a working comedians
do you have a lot of like free time to
do that don't you have to do press and
you think you do you think it's like 18
hours
it's just like maybe two hours in the
morning from like six days yeah but what
do you do in your hotel rooms that's
what i wanted like i play video games so
you bring then i go to movies
so you bring your setup in your room i
remember when i first got with my lady
you know and and like she's she's
helping me pack to go on a road trip and
i'm putting my xbox in my little
carrying case with the monitor it's a
game system
no no she was like
why are you taking your game she's not
really like yeah i go like this well
normally i would chase hoes
and then she goes where's your
controller
so now i just play video games in my
room and i have the amc app so i'll go
to movies if there's i'll find an amc
theater because i get to go to three
movies i can't like i love going to
movies by myself now yeah it's like the
greatest thing to go to movies about
yourself
it likes to get late-night burgers bro
this one so this is fuku
how do you say [ __ ] fuku
mommy
i was in vegas doing shows at the new
wise guys club great club great club
especially for vegas you know vegas yeah
i just don't like being off strip but no
it's great it's like a little close
it's one of my favorite clothes yeah one
of my favorite clothes but it's fuku
burger the owner comes he said you gotta
i get the best burgers in town by a
while so you know my squad we want a big
pun in the tariff squad yeah so we go
there like two in the morning oh that's
you the dude posted a video from a
security footage
like i'm committing a crime on world
star hip hop i'm like bro i texted him
like you know you can just ask me for a
pic man you don't have to pull this
weird security yeah that's kind of weird
that's a weird look he kept doing it
every now and then i'll be afraid of
this crew
yeah he should you guys looking like the
fat street boys
david till you seen david taylor lately
jesus i said goddamn hell boy take it
easy
[Laughter]
what do you guys do in vegas like what's
fun like when you're not doing your sets
there do you guys gamble and stuff i
gamble i hate no i hate casinos can't
stand i mean jeremiah won one on the
slot machines well how much 500
85 year old korean woman what are you
doing at the slot where are you smoking
and slopping yeah
you're shaming me now how did you die
you can't be happy for me and jeremiah
winning any kind of money
how did you guys
how did you guys split the money because
it was it you're okay what happened
no it was a challenge so our challenge
was okay you we have 40 bucks 50 or 40.
whoever
makes the most money wins
the challenge so what ended up happening
is the first machine i went to i went to
the old school ones because the new ones
are like high-tech video i don't know a
lot of grown-ups
all these colors and i don't even know
how to read the machine went to the old
school one put in ten dollars
i won a hundred off of ten i won a
hundred and thirty dollars jesus i
didn't even know i was winning he was
like
and i pressed it again dude
you play the ones where it's like
cherries
did you have a diaper on because you
didn't want to go to the bathroom you
didn't want to leave it you just peed
your pants that's what they took out my
my pay stub i'm like oh 130 dollars i'm
like i'm winning your turn jeremiah he
went to one of the new school machines
the willy wonka in the chocolate factory
there's oompa loompa's like man you know
and he didn't know what was going on
he's like
wild you know we didn't know how to read
it
he ended up winning 121 dollars oh yeah
so i was winning and he proposed this he
goes let's
combine our vouchers and just put it all
on um
black yep type move roulette yeah and
you won we doubled our money oh yeah and
then you got out and we're screaming
like we won the lottery ah yeah then did
you guys take that 500 and go get [ __ ]
in vegas no we went to uh there's a
brazilian there's good um steakhouses
there great yeah he got that dopamine
hip and he just flew him right off yeah
yeah
so we went to fukuo
what do you went to a chain yeah
that's
ridiculous that's great that's
jeremiah's oh yeah kansas ass yeah you
know what i mean let's not do that it's
a real white person
let's go go to chat
we got money stevie let's go
time stamp time step and another time
stamp i how dare you so what what's a
good restaurant then what do we do
what's called herbs and i forget what it
is herbs morton's is morton's good
that's a chicken
but like you know when you go out of
town i hate going like i'm not going to
go to chili's or fridays i want to go to
like what's the thing the restaurant
that's been here especially in vegas
there's like well how do we try to down
there color guys the pad thai out there
the sushis even get a little collar guys
i mean what how do we oh
like how do we know what restaurants
good and bad in vegas like
somebody lives out there i mean you know
you know who's part of wise guys is
polly shore yeah yeah yeah yeah you know
paulie oh wise guys
did he make you do like a polly on the
street with him no no no he knows better
wait he's got paulie on the street he
just goes on he just has his guy film
and you just go with him and he like
just he's just being polly sure he's
like he's actually fun he's funny yeah
he's great it's funny hey buddy come
over tomorrow i'm like he's got a great
place out there great his uh next door
neighbor's uh nick uh nicholas cage oh
really if i explain something he's like
come over and get peanut butter jelly
sandwiches like dude i'm not 14 man i'm
not coming over peanut butter jelly is
good you don't gotta be fourteen to
enjoy peanut butter and jelly but i was
just saying cobble
i ordered room service and i got peanut
butter and jelly all right take it easy
small small flags small flags
and you're judging but i'm not going to
get another grown man like if i was like
hey but that's true though let's come
over on sunday around noon i'm gonna
make some peanut butter and jelly yeah
it should be like it's just already
ready
do you [ __ ] with people yeah
let's take a little break to pay for all
this camera equipment and nick's salary
listen man listen today's program of
king of the sting is brought to you by
athletic greens the health and wellness
company that makes
daily nutrition really really simple man
there's a lot of stress going on out
there but you know your diet's not
perfect so lean into athletic greens man
one tasty scoop of ag1 contains 75
vitamins minerals whole food source
ingredients including a multivitamin
multimineral probiotic green superfood
blend and man it's delicious it's
delicioso baby all right join the
movement of athletes comedians moms dads
rookies first-timers and everyone in
between taking ownership of their daily
health and focusing on nutritional
products that they really need in the
simplest manner possible that's
essentialist nutrition to make it easy
athletic greens is going to give you an
immune supporting free one-year supply
of vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your first purchase if you visit
athletic greens.com kats today again
simply visit athleticgreens.com kats to
take control of your health and give ag
one a try buzz buzz bald bald man two
out of three men will experience some
form of hair loss by the time they are
35. i see a lot of bros at my shows and
a lot of y'all you losing your hair man
more than 50 million bros in the u.s
suffer from male pattern baldness it's
not a good look man looking like jeremy
piven before he got the surgery done
keep offers
simple
stress-free way to keep your hair i'm
talking about keeps k-e-e-p-s
all right it's low-cost treatments are
just ten dollars per month keeps offers
generic versions discreet little package
shows up your girl has doesn't have to
know you're trying to look like fabio
all right prevention is key treatments
can take four to six months to see
results so act fast if you're ready take
action prevent hair loss get that get
that mane out the back like the rat king
go to keeps.com cats that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash cats to receive your first
month of treatment for free that's
keeps.com cats get your first month free
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash cats
i have one quick question to ask you
guys because it's all dudes here
um all dudes so when i okay so i have
this thing with my girl she just she
doesn't want me to fart in bed fair
point but
when i'm laying down
it's go time it's the best time i try i
get up to i try to we have a balcony so
i go outside and i'm out there like ah
it's not working no because when you
move yeah it's just like getting in bed
the fart's like i'm going to lay low
yeah and then you start moving the floor
as soon as my body is perfect yeah and
then you know what i mean and then every
then she's just like she just
went off on me this morning you gotta
take the pillow and silence it like i
said it doesn't matter because it was
like it was a funky one so
she hates it huh oh man she's like i'm
tired of smelling you farts everywhere i
bet you they smell horrible yeah you
just really let them go time stamp that
you just be letting them go huh
but she told me one time she was like i
don't want you to think that you can't
because i don't want you to get sick so
i always wait i always bring that well
you if you don't get that out you can
you can you can eventually get it out
but it's not like some horrible
condition well i like i i kind of play
it up you know i got to get it out my
stomach feel good
so i don't know are you a bed farter no
uh i've never farted in front of my girl
on accident oh wow she's never fired in
front of me either who right you guys
even know each other no no i really like
a 1950s [ __ ] house man there's no you
guys sleep in separate twin beds yeah
yeah well the better question is do you
smell your own farts yeah it's terrible
but is that a better question yeah do
you think that's a better question
i've stuffed that yeah yeah all right i
enjoy it i enjoy it what yeah you have
to enjoy well you know you've never done
that you fart under the covers
it's a dutch oven you know
you can smell
some of it and then you save some for
later stevie's a freak
everybody loves their own brand yeah
this guy's got a question about
something that just came out and
something that's going to come out what
up cats big brandon e money [ __ ]
steves it's your favorite east coaster
matt back again from new york city
with a king interesting it so
dave chappelle's latest comedy special
the closer i don't know if y'all saw it
yet but man to me personally it felt a
little bit more like a cultural ted talk
than it did in comedy interesting
normally dave is a belly full of laughs
this time he was a head full of [ __ ] to
think about so what'd y'all think uh did
you love it did you hate it would you
king it would you sting it did you learn
anything i mean what was the objective
there to be entertained or to be
conflicted you tell me gang gang and
brandon you already know what it is
thank you yes sir
uh
i king it i i thought it was i was
vintage dave chappelle because his uh
prior two i felt were like more like a
ted talk i was like dog just give us
jokes this was loaded with jokes granted
it's controversial also is it
controversial and like people are like
oh let's cancel netflix i'm like first
of all you gotta realize and you've been
through this with showtime whatever
you've had your other specials on like
you submit your hour 30 minutes to them
they have to okay it's not like netflix
saw when we all saw it and we're like oh
my god this transgender stuff's horrible
but they know what's going on but at
this level though it could have been
like that though i doubt it you know but
i'm sure but i'm sure it was like what
are they going to say we're not listen
they saw his hour in live i would
guarantee it right someone from netflix
saw his hour live before they agreed to
that that's the way it works but also
with the transphobic stuff i don't think
dave's transphobic so that was the point
of his special well i had to leave
transformation well i had to look that
you know what's interesting you say that
because i actually talked about this on
my podcast too riffing with griffin i um
the word translation
the word transphobic is like it's not to
me it's not a proper term because
phobia means fear
but transphobic doesn't mean being
afraid of it actually it means what they
are what people think about what they
they like if he
he he like if you look up the dictionary
definition of transphobic i think they
need a different term but you know i
don't know i i agree like you know he
but it became like almost a retread
though because it was like it's almost
like this is a whole continuation from
the last one you know it's not but but
it's also brilliant and funny and also
like
are people really upset or is it just
the internet you know what i'm saying
like yeah well give me context
that's what it says that's almost too
much to get into
but then also it's like
when you like are they upset or is it
just clout chasing like are people just
like
look at us look at us look he made fun
of us look at us well there's a lot of
pay attention over here they've got what
i'm saying they've gotten a lot of
there's been a few transgender comedians
who they've gotten to write like you
know these little op-ed pieces and whose
readings is about those things they're
they're out there coming out you know
i'm saying like who's like when you look
at how many people watch chappelle's
special company how many people doesn't
care i have one issue no he's also hey
he doesn't care also all this is planned
like this is you could have saw this
coming a mile away like he knows exactly
the backlash he's gonna get i my only
it's not an issue it's just it's kind of
like a damn for me
is
um we make the same reference i've been
doing it i've been doing an impossible
[ __ ] joke for three years you know and
so now in regards to transgender yeah
yeah yeah i have a joke in my joke i
believe for me it's like my joke's
softer it's not as you know but i've had
so many people already hit me up that
have seen me live for three years like
oh man you know and is it is it parallel
thing yeah yeah yeah for sure for sure
and that's the thing too but it sucks
because when if someone that famous does
something that's his joke it's his joke
now it's his joke because because these
idiots out here they don't care about
any they don't think about anything it's
like if you say the same word
even if you and this is the second it's
the same premises they're going to be
like oh you still have from right right
yeah because he's more famous
and i totally get so just for my fans i
had i had to talk about it on my podcast
just to be like because all you all my
fans that are hitting me up like oh man
i saw you do this and but you know and i
had to let them know oh no it's just
parallel thinking i don't run in the
same circles as this guy to me i feel
proud that like you know a brilliant guy
like that we came to the same conclusion
you know what i mean but like for me it
sucks because now i can't do it anymore
so it's like it's over for me but like
you know but it is what it is i'm not
i'm not you know you know what i mean
like i said i don't i don't i don't
think this guy stole anything it's just
parallel thinking but it just sucks
because i really loved my joke yeah well
isn't there a hierarchy in the comedy
world like let's say open micro has a
bit that
you're doing too but he had it first
don't you have rank on him no no no it
doesn't work like that it doesn't work
how it works is if you get it on tv
first it's yours
oh because it's solidified yeah it's on
tv because before it was it wasn't as
there wasn't as many specials so like
what i don't like about someone doing so
many specials in a short span of time
this is the only thing i don't like
about it is that's what happens so like
a lot of comics are delving into some of
the same subject matter it cuts the legs
yeah so now all the comics that are
talking about things
now anytime you talk about the same
thing as chappelle or burr or anybody
like that they now that we're stealing
from them and they own every premise
that's the only thing i don't like about
because this happened to me a lot i had
my on my on my second special i was
making this reference uh um
and i used the phrase banana gate okay
and then i'm you know and then like the
chappelle comes out with a special and
he says the same words for something
else and then adam igit at the comment
store he goes yo man you see chappelle's
thing you can't do that banana gate
thing anymore and i was like what then i
saw it and i was like it's not even the
same joke but it don't matter it don't
matter because people are gonna
associate they would associate it so i
was like damn it happened to me even
with bird bird did his saturday night
live uh his monologue when he just
started live
yeah and i and i have i have a i had the
same similar preference about talking
about white women and like uh being you
know slave owners and and and he had the
same thing and i was like i've been
doing i was doing that at the comedy
store so it was like it's one of these
things we just go damn it like you know
it's like you know it's like it's it's a
race to be more famous so you can like
so now i start to think because he goes
to the most famous guy but now i start
to think i need to just start putting my
stuff on the internet i need to just
like this
if it's time yeah like stop worrying
about like let me save it for
respectively
with afghanistan stuff it's like i can't
release this in march right all right i
totally think that [ __ ] needs to come
out it's not going to think you know and
again that's like i say like somebody
like like how prolific chappelle is that
he literally has done like five or six
specials in four years monster three or
four years one was like just current
events but yeah i know but it's like
still but he has he's so you know
dynamic and stuff so it's like that's
all i'm saying is like i wish
you know
you know it's like
it sucks really that the things
comedy's so accessible because of like
netflix youtube that whoever
does a thing now it's as if no other
comic can discuss this now did you see
the transgender who is referencing to
during the special she committed suicide
and uh the family came out because you
know she stuck up for him with one on
one of his special she stuck up for him
and she just got bombarded by the lgq bt
community like lit the [ __ ] up and he
was like you know i don't know if you
guys helped with her commit suicide
definitely didn't you know definitely
help out like whatever you bullying this
girl definitely help out i'm not saying
that's why she committed suicide
definitely didn't help though but he was
inferring that correct and it
but it was part of the thing too for
sure but then
that so the cause she's gone now right
commit suicide the family came out
recently like a few days ago and
defended dave chappelle was like
whatever her name was phoebe would have
loved these jokes wouldn't have been
offended would have loved these jokes so
who's really offended you know what i'm
saying yeah or is it just a good way to
go oh look we're here here we are
i know it sucks um
yeah but it's like an ally yeah but it's
just like he said like you know the uh
the twitter's not a real place he really
feels that way and bill burr feels the
same way too like bill like you know he
had some things and he was like this is
going to go away whether there's 40
people on the internet that don't like
what i said and then they just move on
the news cycle you know so fast that's
where i'm at i don't i'm in agreeance
with them i don't think social media is
real i really don't but i think that all
the critics that were trying to trash
chappelle for sticks and stones
they were misguided and he won an emmy
yep but i think all the criticism they
were making of that special can apply to
this one yep and this one i don't think
is going to have the same impact as the
last one ooh i disagree yeah i think
this one was better but we're king and
closer all of us right yes yeah yeah
it's not my favorite dave chappelle kind
of sting it just in the context of how
much i love dave chappelle i i i thought
it was his best special last five years
oh
yeah i'm not with you at all
because i think i think he was uh
he's a great orator you know he's a
really fantastic orator so that's just
you know his speaking and how he
presents himself he really you know
exactly how he feels and what he's
saying um but it don't mean it's always
funny if you look at like killing him
softly like back in the day skinny
chappelle show and he's like that baby's
on the street doing crack like that's
that's cop yeah i like skinny chabelle
yeah yeah yeah but he's older now i know
he's more mature like you know
he's like you know but i i feel like he
needs he needed to evolve past all this
transgender [ __ ] way sooner but the
thing is just to like put a button on it
it's like i get like he's in such a
great position like his
his specials they're really podcasts you
know they're really podcasts so he was
able to do one and then all the critics
whatever things were saying he was like
you know what i can address this again
yeah and another one i could be like you
know y'all were talking [ __ ] so now i'm
back again to reiterate what i was
saying and to challenge this nonsense
and then if people come at him again
he's like all right let me do another
one yeah yeah you know 20 million every
time yeah what a great position to be in
to like challenge everything that people
say about him and then double
yeah he doubled down emmys doubled and
when emmy's on it so it's like it's it's
like he's one of the few people in that
position it's almost like jokes on you
yeah the joke's on you man wow see what
this guy's got yo
king understand this brian laundry
jacob coming from mexico
yep yep it is jacob also known as brian
got a king of her sting it for you since
theo's vaughn special is coming on
netflix october 19th yes you better go
and watch it
where are we gonna go
for you stevie weeby doing stand up
i personally want to see it i think
stevie's a hilarious guy
and i think he'd make a lot of people
laugh
but yeah it's my king and her stinging
stevie doing stand up
gang gang
can i tell you something
this guy's facial hair he is messing up
those pretty ass eyes no it's just he's
a beautiful looking man he's
i am all for this i talked to theo this
morning okay he called me to check in
you know he's like uh
steve because i think we should do some
king of the thing shows it'll be fun i
think we should do shows live shows oh
lord i'll do stand up and we all do
stand up
yeah tv host and does like five minutes
so much anxiety
this is gonna happen
i was gonna i was gonna do okay so i was
in vegas with jeremiah he was doing wise
guys the second show
one of the um comedians didn't show up
so i'm in the green room
and i don't know why i said this but i
was just trying to be of service and i'm
like hey
i'll go out there
he was this close of letting me go on i
just didn't have he should have but i
had nothing brennan i had no well steve
moving forward nothing new
that's why he didn't let me go because
he's like well would you because he was
like trying to safeguard me he's like
okay okay i'll let you do but what are
you going to talk about like let's talk
and you had nothing i have like well
first of all what you talk you can't be
talking outstanding with jeremiah
dude time stamp that
that was
that
piece of [ __ ]
no no no no no no i'm not letting this
slide oh you're gonna let it slide
has seen you you have seniority over
theo too yeah maybe that don't matter
i'm just i'm just trying to figure you
guys out
hold up no how does this work how many
how famous is your podcast as a
seniority you know what i mean how does
it work so you know lowest on the totem
pole for that no
so you guys are above him on the
comments no there's no there's no
secrets he stopped saying that there's
no such thing
but we know who's funnier
steve i'm not i'm not
i love jeremiah you know but what i'm
just teasing both of you but steve
moving forward from this day
out what's the worst that could happen i
already bumped i already
this is what you don't realize just you
being like this is funny like this would
work literally doesn't listen steve
movie you're gonna host it from now
you're gonna start writing jokes down
and we're gonna check in with you every
episode how are the jokes going steve
and this is what we're going to do so we
need that's our new segment how do you
write a joke it could be good income for
you yeah how do you write a joke you
have somebody don't have ideas on things
so is it do you just write premises yes
starts with a seed with a premise give
me an example oh okay steve i'll give
you an example right now we're doing a
joke writing no no steven workshop right
now yeah okay so here's our notebooks
out no you're gonna you're what what
what a premise is
like you is you explaining why you think
it's funny so what do you find funny say
in your apartment
um
there's a whole lot exactly like what
well the hot plate
what else i'm trying to tell steve why
the thing is this is the joke what about
the black why is it funny exactly the
black blood's good why is it funny to
you and that's the premise
and then you're going to talk about it i
have to get this off my chest though
because i have had some dms of
specifically uh referring to the black
butt steve's add is off the chain saying
that
saying that bypass i can no longer
support you because of the black box
because it's black because fake butt no
he was commenting because it was it
would look like a smaller robot
and have kids and that bothered me but i
know you and you're a good person choose
that it was given to me sure
and it's not like i had it out all the
time you saw him
everybody that's what everybody said
that went to jeffrey epstein's island
yeah
yeah you could write on that all day but
isn't that kind of hacky no
you know what this is my thought process
behind that it's like oh you don't want
to talk about a flashlight no no no no
no stevie you're missing the point you
know it's not hacky because it's real
yeah that's personal it's real to you
yeah now if we did it and we don't have
that that's hacky yeah but it's real
it's hacky if someone else it's not it's
organic to stevie no but i thought this
might have i what i thought
it was is if you if someone else covered
that subject matter no you can't do that
bro no no because so-and-so
steve you're talking about something
completely different hackie is a subject
with define hacking okay that's hacky is
just a subject that is very common and
uh it's not the surface level of a joke
so a hacky joke would be like talking
about the the um uh side effects of
medication that's a hacky joke like or
flying on an airplane any airplane
materials every comment because that's
someone's experience you're saying
but now if you're at a high level to you
if you have unique
unique uh covet jokes are becoming hacky
now uh just anything that's like a
common you know trump jokes yeah trump
drugs people over that but but again all
something that's common you're missing
all this like that black butt is
personal and that's your story
so you have a personal take on it yeah
now if you were like oh what if i did a
joke about a bla a big black dick well
you don't have a big black dick that
makes no sense dude i don't have it
are you saying do i have do you
i don't know
i love the story you told about the
first time you did stand up when you
were arguing afterwards with your mom
about what was funny that's literally
that could be super funny yeah listen
you remember
that could be a joke in itself like
hopefully this goes better because last
time boom off the races last time i did
it you know what happened brendan i
should have i got off my horse i never
hop back on the horse well
me and eric can i tell you because that
that was so traumatic for me well i
thought cause you ate the horse
are you gonna back me up it doesn't have
nothing to do with asians either eating
horses eat animals man not horses
you do yeah
this should be something you should take
confidence in getting back on stage eric
who's been calling me forever even has
taught comedy before says stevie do it
yeah actually do it that's the geo who's
been doing comedy for 90 years says do
it i think it's all about support i
think it's just about you honing in on
why you're funny you don't know why
you're funny but see that's what's funny
but that's the problem i don't know but
as a comic you need to understand you
need to understand why why funny and
once you tone but that's the problem
there i i don't mean to be funny yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's why i think this
works
i disagree i i disagree
as a listen when steve figures out why
he's funny then he'll be able to really
manipulate because that's what this is
about it's about manipulating why you're
[ __ ] proud i don't know stevie you're
funny because you're very unique
okay so i could maybe unique subject to
topics or something no but see again
it's more your view
on i'm trying to tell you
he doesn't understand yeah
once he figures it out yeah that's
awesome let me give an example steve
when i used to coach uh when i used to
coach basketball and just before i was
doing stand-up you know and i'd be on
the sidelines and i'd be yelling at the
kids and then the crowd would laugh you
know yeah and then i'd be like i'm
saying things to them and then people
are laughing and then it was like a
moment i figured out i was like oh so
people think it's funny when i'm upset
and there is a sort of like heightened
performance because i would say things
to the kids like are you point shaving
you know what i mean it's like you know
the kids came to me when the kids were
like coach can you like can you stop
making fun of us you know like because
like people are laughing at us and i was
like
it was one of the moments where i was
like oh i and i knew why it was funny
yeah like i understood exactly why i was
funny i understood exactly what i was
doing and i understood it was like this
is funny to people you figured out your
flavor i figured out my thing so steve
just doesn't really understand yeah i'll
give you an example these little things
that he does you know like we did not
listening is
like not listening
i'm getting you know what i'm doing
podcast live and i noticed since there
was a live audience i kept
looking
at them for like approval conference
yeah
and they saw through that
and i felt like they they can there's a
weird kind of energy like they could
sense certain things did they like it or
no
i i don't i can't tell
that's just exactly see that's a very
interesting perception steve is that
this is the thing why you know if you're
a comic like i always tell young comics
like don't apologize for things that you
stay on stage meaning like don't come
across like you know you're saying
something bad because the audience is
going to be like yeah you're not
supposed to say that and they'll pick up
on that energy that's what i'm talking
about there's some weird line
spoken energy thing with the i'm going
to figure it out
man i'm telling you so it's like the
matrix like you could figure out little
yes let's take a little break and then
we'll be right back on the show
listen man we all want to give our girl
or your guy
something special man to celebrate
something an engagement how about
engagement ring of her dreams how about
some diamond stud errand for your man
whatever it is man let blue now help you
because they're in the business of
wedding jewelry engagement rings bands
everyday fine jewelry diamond jewelry
cocktail rings gemstone necklaces we got
it all man with your customizing
engagement ring or design diamond stud
earrings at bluenow.com you're in
control all right you guys ready to pop
the question or pop some freaking rings
or earrings in your man's ear your mans
at bluenow.com choose from more than a
hundred thousand ethically sourced gi a
graded diamonds in every shape and size
they got endless selection so you can
give her the pendant or the ring or
errands of her or his dreams
bluedial.com kids they got expert advice
24 7. legendary service with 30 day
returns
so if this sounds something nice man
make the moment sparkle with jewelry
from bluenow.com kingston listeners and
viewers get 50 bucks off 500 this is a
podcast exclusive offers includes
engagement all right use codes k-a-t-s
that's code k-a-t-s plus every order's
insured ships free arrives discreet
little packaging that won't give away
what's inside shop stress free and find
your forever piece go to bluenow.com
today
i know none of y'all be watching that
freaky porn but just in case if you have
any friends or family that do you'll
want to pay attention to this little ad
right now with everything going on in
the world governments have increased
their surveillance they're watching us
man they're using your device track your
location movements and in many countries
your internet activity that's right you
want to be caught with your pants down
don't want mom to catch it dude and one
of the best ways to keep your online
browsing activity private is by using
the expressvpn
when you use expressvpn your internet
connection is rerouted through a secure
encrypted server so you can surf the web
free man you don't have to look over
your shoulder all right look i know you
probably think all you have to do is go
incognito mode wrong that don't work man
they can still track you they can still
freaking track you that's why i use
expressvpn whenever i go online to look
at all the creepy stuff and i recommend
you guys do the same without expressvpn
you're giving people a free license to
peek over your shoulder and see all the
freaky stuff you're into so protect your
privacy today and get three months of
expressvpn for free visit expressvpn.com
cats that's expressvpn.com
cats e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n
dot com slash cats to learn more
is this a trailer for theo special yeah
let's do this and let me say it's where
he plays about theo special so theo's
special is called regular people
you know theo he's crazy right and he
had a million pictures that netflix sent
him for marketing and he goes man i
don't like this one i look too silly i
don't like this one i said theo here's
the thing about you calling you special
regular people you're the furthest thing
from regular that i've ever used so your
picture should be your like he it was
one was far away one looked like marc
maron on a stool i'm like no i don't
want any of that he's like don't look
goofy in this picture i'm like no that's
how you look dog so by calling it
regular people having this picture yeah
to me that's [ __ ] funny yeah i had a
fun you know
my first special was called the ugly
truth so i had a real ugly picture of me
it was like my belly and stuff and i was
like what's the ugly truth yeah
so this is what i'm saying like you were
so right and i saw your regular person
theo like this is his
there's certain times i think in
comics careers some it happens early
some happens late but
that's hilarious
that's hilarious laughing too hard no no
no no
no no no i want to point something out
steve why is that funny to you it's just
uh
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no this is this is a chat steve look
at me look at me look at me listen
there's the don't listen
wait listen the poster looks fine no
steve listen i want you to really think
about this
why did you laugh so hard when you saw
that right now think about the whole
thing why did you laugh so hard i don't
want to fat shame you though no no no
no why not steve now why is that funny
well you look fatter okay so why is it
the ugly truth that's the truth right so
what i'm saying is like steve this is
how you make jokes okay because this is
what i'm saying like why did you laugh
when you understand why you laugh at
things you will explain why you laugh at
things but i'll say jokes but also why
why it works too stevie's because you're
a sweet person you have a good soul is
he
he is he is otherwise you wouldn't be
here but the other thing about so this
is the last thing on theo so theo had a
special on netflix a while ago not his
best work we can all admit that
feel from that special to now i told him
i said brother when this comes out this
is your this is your moment you know
theo is like no man there's no moments
i'm telling you dude i've seen your
material
for for your fans are going to watch it
regardless but the casual fan is like
you know regular people and that guy
looks silly clicks on it dude it's gonna
[ __ ] catapult
his head's already big and his nose and
his ass it's gonna be even bigger
because when people get a hold of
them around here
and he's going to watch this he doesn't
realize this moment in his career he
won't acknowledge it why not he doesn't
like pressure
man
this is special
number one on netflix so i think it
helps yeah if you can it drops next
wednesday october 19th but if you go
visit the page that it's on that helps
it
let's see and rate it and give it thumbs
up yeah support it's awesome i grew up
around regular people you know
just you know
like out there everybody's fancy
somebody's fancy their daddy's fancy you
know
i grew up dude they had a guy growing up
in my neighborhood no arms fight
everybody boy
boy look at him yeah zero arms
this boy named kurt was his name
yeah
well that his name was edgerton okay
nobody's named gert that's not a name
you know
that's more like a sound you know like
maybe you're you're eating something and
somebody scares you know kurt
that's just mom petting the cat
you call before you come touch that cat
linda
this fellow named edgerton
and he choked out 30 people in our town
and had zero arm
[Laughter]
and they call him gert because if you
take the name edgerton
and you take off the e.d and you take
off the o-n
then nas skirt you know
yeah just the middle you know just like
him really
my dog oh fantastic i'm excited for him
yeah that's exciting i love that picture
wow look at this is a big deal his
billboard's cool too that's the best
place for a special netflix right now it
is depends yeah i think they thought
that that was the premier place
if you're a theo yes if they push you
yeah so what can compete with that
though it's not youtube comedy central
not comedy central hold on central
youtube like i think if are they finally
on youtube because you know for a long
time
they were trying to make us go to their
little alley app nope they're on there
what happened to hbo i thought back in
the day it was hbo because here's hbo
like they have a good amount of
subscribers but netflix has more so
netflix and
to me unless you're like a theo vaughn
or bill burr or dave chappelle
and they're going to push it and promote
it or joe rogan that makes sense but if
you're just a dude and you get lost in
the algorithms yeah nobody's going to
see it and and once here's the other
thing about netflix once you give them
the special it's theirs forever you
can't take clips yeah
ownership you can't take clips and put
on youtube none of that why not at all
dude oh that's nice so if you look at
like shane gillis right
mark norman had the third most watched
special last year
two two three million views shane gillis
over 1.5 million views like if you want
to sell tickets if you wanna sell
tickets unless you're dave chappelle or
bill burr you gotta have that on youtube
in some form whether it's like comedy
center youtube yes you're on youtube you
have to do something because you know
even even for me like
mine being you are on show time
nobody watches showtime it's tough like
because it's not because
especially my fan base 1836 males
they're they love showtime no they
they're they're on youtube
youtube stuff
it's tough but i mean the thing that was
like and also i don't mean to rep you
but also like
the narrative of like
you know putting your special on youtube
it's changing because talents like mark
norman and shane gillis and these other
monsters have are putting their specials
on there i think even rogan's talked
about putting a special on there to get
maximum views
because at first it used to be like kind
of cd-list comics were like nobody's
picking my [ __ ] up and put on youtube
but now it's different cuz you got
monsters monsters doing it even like you
know brett ernst put his special on
youtube and he got a lot of great rev
like he's a mo
write-ups about it so how do you get
paid if
is it monetization google ad like how do
you get people so yeah so it's not all
about getting paid it's not just oh it's
promotion correct because the number one
thing eric and i want to do is sell
tickets on the road that's where we make
our promotion to get the tickets uh so
if you get two million views on youtube
that's going to correlate to tickets on
the road and that's where we make that
that's how you make your money and you
can't do that with netflix you say they
own all these you can't make your nut
but like you know i'm not gonna say how
much deal made but he made enough money
oh he got sense oh the deal he made okay
like chappelle gets like 20 30 million a
time you know rogan gets millions but
someone like that they got a different
type of deal i mean they could tell
definitely yeah he could be like no you
don't you can own this for a year and
then i get it back i mean depending on
who it is who it is yeah but this is the
other thing too with specials it's like
now even on netflix
we know people stop watching after 28
minutes they might come back to it
but they start watching twitch is that
how so let's say uh let's say my friends
and family don't know who eric is and he
has a special and it's on netflix i can
say hey watch eric special on netflix or
if he's on youtube or comedy center
youtube clips i'd take a cl
bro check out eric's [ __ ] bit
you know what i'm saying i think he
stole that bit from chappelle
but shout out to theo man october 1.
yeah go check that out man 19th october
19th wednesday october and here's the
thing he he's a perfect position too
because
specials that come after chappelle
because it's this comedy thing get more
views so it's perfect timing doug how do
you know so much about these algorithms
and marketing business
you are a business that's why we had us
that's why we had a studio called thick
boy
you know what i mean we got a couple he
only he only plays dumb
no you're with me you know you know what
you're doing man
you know what's going on uh we got a
couple quick uh cats in the wild someone
said they saw young brendan
and chuck e cheese
that was of course before the tragedy at
chuck e cheese in your hometown oh my
gosh what do you mean what someone had
shout out to nathan dunlap wait wait
wait nick what is that i don't want to
bring the energy okay oh yeah yeah
can i tell them real quick yeah just
give me a brief summary there was a guy
who went to my high school nathan dunlap
got fired from chuck e cheese went in
there with a assault rifle and murdered
i think five people
so where he ran to the apartments that's
where i lived right behind it so when he
was running my mom's like get in the
house because i was playing football
outside it was late me and my friends
playing and there's helicopters all over
and he's on the news yeah
crazy never forget that never step foot
into chubby cheese again ever in my life
and that's why you get triggered when
you see the rat king correct
oh
it's creepy doug i don't understand like
if you get fired and you're mad
why are you killing other people kill
yourself no i'm just kidding
but time stamp that i really don't want
no that's actually fair
that's actually really fair because they
because they end up killing themselves
anyway a lot of times yeah how about
this you know what's good play a video
game you could kill on the video game
yeah just play
or punch a pillow i don't know or four
fight them i'd rather you fight them and
shoot them yeah come in that's not cool
man but the chucky cheese would be like
nine year olds remember that was back in
the day but it was closed so he came in
after hours through the back door and
the guy that he shot in the face who
survived he actually played dead and
then nathan dumb dunlap uh ran out the
back he ran out the back to the
apartment right came to our friend's
house the guy's face is like all [ __ ]
up you know me and chin have a little
shame in that category huh what happened
cho
oh not us though it's just a korean
texture that was crazy he was a korean
guy yeah are you taking responsibility
there's a little shame right chin of
course you do feel ashamed because
you always you always want them to not
be korean when you see someone asian
yeah that doesn't matter once you find
out you're not like
something else it's rare it's any other
race but white doesn't
he just
snapped yeah snapper i thought that was
like a derogatory no no no he snapped he
stopped red zoned i remember that movie
i told you to watch old boy yeah don't
ever
don't read into it just watch the movie
that kid was kind of inspired by old boy
too because he had the hammer i didn't
know that yeah he took a picture with a
hammer and the hammer is like
significant to msnbc yeah
yeah old boy
is incredible
have you seen you haven't seen old it
was you've got it it was unknown
you
uh please watch it but don't look into
it just watch it you just gotta watch it
right now you'll blow your mind got one
more cats in the wild someone spotted uh
theo in japan
[Applause]
the style with the hair really yeah
that's fantastic
he might want to go to this style
uh so and we'll move on to some debate
clubs another topical thing that
happened yeah yeah yeah
hey what's up guys what's up brandon
what's up theo what's up brandon eric
what's up stevie weeby it's steve c
weeby [ __ ] it's steve it's okay just
call me steven it's okay it's stewie
steve stevie
steve god sorry okay i'll have a debate
club for you guys he for sure took a
bigger l this week um
the head coach of the oakland raiders uh
john gruden
uh who apparently
made some
homophobic and racist remarks through
emails through the last seven years
or the ceo of southwest airlines
uh what do you do again what happened
with that guy i don't know i'll tell you
man
i don't know that contact a bunch of
flights but he's saying he has a bad
weather
and air traffic controls yeah so he
basically mandated a vaccine and blamed
it on air traffic control
uh so their employees are dropping like
flies they're they're anyways they're
protesting who you think took the
biggest l
um
i personally think it was john gruden
yes with the raiders but uh
thanks guys see ya i like these two so
what's the south so so southwest made
vaccines mandatory
for employees for the employees so all
the all the the flight attendants and
the pilots they went on protest so i was
in vegas this past weekend flying back
home and i get there and the lady from
clear is like honey just nice black lady
she's like honey you sure your flight's
going out i'm like yeah why wouldn't it
because i'm on social media i don't know
what the [ __ ] going on and she goes
you know they're because the vaccine
mandate um they're protesting so they
canceled 500 flights out of here she's
like most people flights are canceled
i'm like what the [ __ ] so i looked it up
my flight was still good but
what's in she goes now they're going to
tell you because the weather she was how
was the weathering camera there's not a
[ __ ] clown in the guys you're going
to hear its weather it's not weather
honey and the reason why they have to
say weather you know why they don't want
the backlash right no no no no they have
to say weather because then they don't
have to pay for hotels and all that
stuff
if if it's their fault then they have to
cover you that makes sense yeah so
they're like oh so southwest did that
they're gonna they're losing their ass
they're gonna have to backstep on that
and then you know john what happened
with john gruden oh yeah yeah i want to
ask you about i was saying about you
about john gruder i have a lot
of it to me i don't know what happened
explain it to me i'll actually do so
the way this john green thing happened
is there's an investigation going on
with the the washington football team
aka the redskins right and dan snyder
there's all this shady [ __ ] he's a
complete piece of [ __ ]
why why that's too much to get into okay
just take our word for it so he's a bad
dude for a million reasons and there's
been an ongoing investigation within his
organization
them looking into his organization the
computer thing they found
650 emails from john gruden to dan
snyder and the owner there and a bunch
of other guys and in those emails out of
like from 2008 to 2018 there's emails
calling roger goodell a maggot but with
an f there's him saying uh you know like
this guy has mitchell entire lips
referring to a black guy with big lips
like uh
yeah and then he calls roger goodell
like a clue clueless [ __ ] all this
stuff so it's all these emails
gotcha
he did so i'm and i'm sure like
he should be fired because yeah
70 that nfl is black nobody's gonna
respect him nobody's gonna listen so you
gotta get him out there just from a
football standpoint
to me to me the
bigger
you look at the bigger picture and i'm
not condoning what he did but if we went
through everyone's texts and emails in
here when you were emotional because he
was emotional at that time because the
nfl was gonna do a lockout lockdown do
all that [ __ ] so he's emotional sending
his emails
doesn't you know excuse him for it but
i'm just saying if if you look at take
it outside of football into the real
world and we start looking at all your
emails and texts right there's me some
[ __ ] in there you can get some [ __ ] for
it well so looking as personal emails to
me
it's kind of it's it's kind of dicey man
i know i know i know what you're saying
but here's my connect let me i'll this
is the white part of eric or the black
part this is all parts all right all
right
um
if you say stuff in private
and once it becomes public you have to
answer for it even if you didn't mean it
or not i mean the analogy i use is like
if you walk past your mom and you step
on her foot you didn't do it on purpose
but you're still gonna say sorry
you know and so yeah but should you be
canceled no no no you saw your mom step
on it no no but here's the thing though
here's the thing though she's canceled
or not like he's not he
he quit
he resigned even though they were gonna
have but they were gonna fall for a lot
of the reasons you're saying about and i
i think they went to him and said you
know we can use this clause uh you know
i'm sure he has a clause a character
clause in his contract we can nullify
this whole 100 million dollars or you
can resign and we'll let you get this
amount so i'm sure there's some behind
the scenes thing there and like you said
about you know it's it's over 80 percent
black in the nfl so he's gonna have to
come in there and deal with that yeah so
it's probably like bet and they weren't
winning so it's probably they were
though this is a great no they're not in
the last no no they they lost two games
in a row now and they haven't looked
good
you know it's like they're on the right
track yeah they're three and two and
there's other teams that are better but
anyway so here's my thing about
this it like he's the now the fall guy
but he was sending emails like this to
big boys to other people but not just
other people big boys i know for seven
years right
and and
and they had nothing to say
like we haven't heard the other side
just a bigger problem that's where i'm
at with it yeah this is a bigger problem
the problem is dan schneider bro the
problem is what's all of this i'm not
what i'm saying is this it's all of it
like because there's like here's my
thing here so if
you and i have an email chain for 10
years right and because they're older so
emails to them are like texts right
they're not texting and they're [ __ ]
emailing each other so they were sending
pictures of naked uh cheerleaders from
the washington football team which is a
whole nother thing yeah yeah so dan
snyder forced these cheerleaders to fly
across the seas and then they forced
them to go on dates with these upper
echelon guys basically human trafficking
yeah
that's fact we know that for nothing
happened to him he's a billionaire he's
the one you want to go after he's the
harvey weinstein of all this [ __ ] yeah
yeah i feel like gruden through his
emails is the fall guy that's why he
can't [ __ ] with dan snyder he's a
billionaire yeah but but john but is
there something to it where he's not a
good i mean he's like he he wasn't being
a good guy in this moment but what he
was doing was he thought he was making a
private he thought he was sending
private stuff that was just gonna be
between him and his body
is that not okay
no no what i'm saying is like listen
listen what we're talking about right
because it's a private conversation no
let me let me let me let me finish here
what we're saying is like like as a
comic i totally get this because as a
comic we say a lot of outlandish [ __ ] to
each other especially like a group tag
in a group text we say a lot of
outlander [ __ ] to each other but when
that becomes public you do have to
answer for it i don't think so no it
does dude if you're saying something
like if you if we're making fun of
somebody that's a friend or a colleague
and we're saying things about them in a
text and that stuff comes to light you
got to answer for it you're going to
have to tell them to go to that person
and be like and we were just messing
around man and it was like you know you
have to explain yourself it is what it
is all right so he was saying all this
stuff right yeah you know roger
goodell's gonna be like yo dude that's
how you felt about me yeah he if if he
feels like now he could be like yeah i
felt that way because you did this this
and this that's their private thing but
it did become public and once things
become public you have to answer for
them now what and now how far does that
go is what you're talking about should a
person be canceled should their jobs
their lives livelihood be taken away and
all that kind of stuff that's the whole
other discussion but what we're really
talking about not right now is is he a
good or bad guy and they're trying to
determine that based off this being
racist or whatever it's about a pattern
of behavior not a moment in time so like
if you're in your car and like you know
stevie cuts you off and you're gonna
make some terrible asian joke in your
head in your car you're like oh of
course a freaking asian or a woman or
you know oh look at this fat guy you
know we always go to like our like
that's what trolls do trolls are just
shallow base level things that they say
and they and they come at you and they
like you know you oh you're old you're
fat you're whatever they come to those
things and that's
when you really want to judge somebody
is like in their calm moments
you know and they're like regular every
day he's talking more on privacy his
thing you're talking about two different
things he's talking about uh issue of
privacy
like you know like because
these guys thought in private you know
just talking to the homies like and only
they're all really close friends
for a year because i know i know how
much i just said yeah i know but what
i'm saying is once something becomes
public even though it's not meant to be
it's like it's not it's not matter
though it does though here no it doesn't
because if you knew that i was going to
get out and still talk like it's like oh
you're a piece of [ __ ] no no i i
understand that but once it's also
like once something becomes public you
have to answer for it you can't your
excuse can't be well this was just
between me and my friend we go yeah but
like we saw it so we saw you say
something really outlandish and it comes
across as racist homophobic misogynistic
whatever the things you're gonna say so
would you give them opacity like yeah we
[ __ ] like this all the time that's
how many my friends talk i didn't mean
to offend anybody because this is how
this is how we talk to each other i know
this isn't for the public i understand
that but like
right and so you're let's say you're
offended by it but he's like this wasn't
for you bro i know i understand that but
it's out and he's like yeah i know it's
out and i wish he didn't see those
things that's what he said but it's not
for you i know but that's what he said
but the thing is it's still if he
offended people those people are allowed
to have feelings about it like i don't
care that you were saying that to your
friend so you were talking [ __ ] behind
my back and now it got to me i could
have feelings about that if there's an
email chain with like you and stevie and
they're being like i don't know if i
like eric on the show because he's a
blah blah blah
it doesn't matter even if you were
joking okay he's saying it's okay so if
you were joking and saying some racist
homophobic stuff about me
and i got out i'm allowed to be like yo
dude you know what the difference is
what what's up what's up so let's say
you and stevie had a text thread let's
say you and stevie has text yeah go
ahead brandon and you're making fun of
me like doing all this [ __ ] oh we do
this yeah i'm sure like clown like right
clowning me doing all this [ __ ] and then
he accidentally sent me that i was like
yo duck what the [ __ ] what what's up and
you're like ah we're just [ __ ] around
that's how i've been like oh that makes
sense
here's the thing though but we're
friends
those guys are friends
not the people they were talking about
okay fair point not the people they were
talking about but let's come up with a
solution so i understand there's no
sense there's no there is there is a
solution there is no there is a there's
a how about you just be a good person
100 of the time you don't drop then bomb
you're just a good person that way you
don't have to worry about anything okay
so you don't have anything that's the
idealistic way to think yeah and that's
what and that's what that's what
twitter's trying to make everybody feel
like yeah and what brendan is cause i
never dropped those well i never say
those words oh sometimes when i'm
playing warzone i might say
i might slip up i never say the n bomb
but mine might say
a different word and be like [ __ ] you
know or you know or but
but at that time that doesn't represent
stevie as a human being is what i'm
trying to say
oh that's because you've got a
heightened sense there and you're trying
to say whatever it is to hurt that kid
whatever you shot in the face with a
fake i don't know who i i don't know who
shot me it's just i'm just angry that i
lost but you know by saying whatever you
say is the same as this email though
because he knew exactly who he was
talking to he knew exactly what he was
saying he chose his words carefully when
you're sitting in front of a computer
and you are writing like you don't write
how you talk you don't i don't go like
you stupid
and then i send no he wrote that out man
he thought that out he he and then you
know and he did it and he sent it oh i
see you're pointing out so yeah so so
it's okay that like premeditated he was
pre-meditated so he said this to uh he
sent it to people he thought you know it
was like it was this is going to be
between us and i get that point i'm not
just i'm not getting i'm not taking away
that point what i'm saying is it you it
does not excuse
his language and behavior don't excuse
it
i'm not saying that's who he is all i'm
saying is it don't excuse it when the
person hears about it i'm okay with
these people coming out and being like
hey man you want to talk outside about
what you're saying about me it's okay
and it's not up to him to say it's not
up to gruden to say hey guys i'm not
racist i just said this privately i
don't care you know what you talk about
me yeah so i i will let you know when
i'm over it you know and that's what
happened in this situation so he was
like man it's a lot of smoke he didn't
want to deal with it he made his 35
million dollars
he didn't want to coach anyway he you
know he came back into it but i don't
think he can deal with all this smoke
the league's different now and he's just
like you know what i'm good i'm out cool
well i stand by this brendan has lips
like michelin tires too
he got them to you no you don't see
nothing bad you know come on
brandon you you i have some dear sweet
guy
what are you saying you don't say
nothing like
i mean our group chats you know with
comics like with brian delir or me
rogan's you know it's like if that's
stuff language changes
because you're talking to the homies
like the language it changes a little
bit but if that were filmed and it was
put out i'd be accountable for it you'd
have to be accountable for it that's all
i'm saying let's see what she's got to
say oh okay
here we go on to the next this little
apocalypto done alice from new york city
um so my boyfriend recently
admitted that he speed in our kitchen
sink i've done that a million times i'm
pretty shocked i feel like a [ __ ] um
hell's angel when i do it and i still
can't believe that he's done it
oh that's nothing done this a couple of
times
well steve not everybody's sinking
toilet is the same thing
what do you guys think
everyone watches their dishes in their
toilets
first of all dude put the dishes
because you're shaming my apartment
again and that's a private thing that uh
you know
i feel like i like this in gatorade
bottles i feel like i've done that
million times i feel like only girls
have a problem with people peeing in
singing so i do it all the time all the
time hotels my girl if we both have to
take a piss
both we're like a hotel and there's one
bathroom and we rushed in our bag it
should be like yeah i gotta pee i'm like
me too you know what happens i'm peeing
in the sink but you know what happens
when you keep doing that because i i was
addicted to it at one point
in the sink yeah don't ask me why it is
addictive that's a two-hour thing it is
freeing but you know what happens in the
piping
there's these little fruit
flies doug yeah fruit flies don't come
from no no there's something there's a
little flower sounds like that thing
right now it's coming out of the hole
because you gotta pour bleach down there
and clean your apartment sometimes yes
stevie also it sounds like you're
[ __ ] in the sink yeah
thanks for tuning in guys
another great episode you know the part
of the toilet you you know that part
yeah with the water that's where steve
keeps dishes
what did you say
hold up what did you just say
you say it again no we're time stamping
thanks for tuning in guys
that's terrible by the way we didn't
even answer her like i think it's like
you have to have a hygiene talk with
your man that's all look you can't
unknow what you know listen now every
time she looks at that sink she's like
there's p in there it's just p baby what
i mean it's just p basically it's just
pissed yeah p
well if she steps on the jellyfish he's
gonna be like well i guess you don't
want my peanuts
yeah that's dead that's dirty
all right let's see what this guy's got
oh oh no
i gotta can't sting it for you boys
playing on trampolines
i don't know on the other day fractured
my neck
got a plate put in the back after a
seven-hour surgery [ __ ]
oh i'm gonna take the opportunity to
roast the hosts
brandon you look like a general manager
at the last sharper image on earth
you feel you look like you run an ant
farm factory
uh buzz buzz neck plate
guys love the show thanks i love this
guy okay well first of all he needed to
add to it a grown person drinking on a
trampoline yeah yeah yeah sting it
you know besides pools uh trampolines
are the most dangerous thing for kids a
little longer grown-ass adult i'd stay
that must be difficult like are you
telling your kids not to do dangerous
stuff they're like look at your ears dad
talking about dangerous stuff yeah
you're getting your body pounded you
know what i just noticed you call it i
just never know it's my ears before no i
just noticed that right now yeah
so that's kind of you are you know
you're gonna be one of those like what
if your kids want to fight you
absolutely not no it's so interesting i
don't know are they going to wrestle
right now
because you know like you see how the
sausage is made you know what i'm saying
yeah but but your kid is also going to
be like but dad look what this provided
for us no i get it i want to do the same
yeah and i went through this shane got
ct so you don't have to yeah
i'm with you on that who's this dying
wow you're [ __ ] strong
you got me fired up
i'm sorry i saw those tits
we covered this a little bit earlier but
yes
we'll see
hi brendan hi theo
stevie montez
i think you guys should come to
nashville and film a live king in this
thing i think it would be so fun you
guys can come out and
go through broadway and all through
nashville um but come to zanies and have
a live taping of king and this thing i
think that would be awesome tickets on
me
girls coming
um so yeah king of this thing
are you guys coming or not broadway
well you know what i'm coming back to
you king her i told theo yes this
morning i said we should do some king in
the sting shows
live shows steve here's the plan stevie
hosts it yeah he's going to do it if you
come out do 15 then you come out do
whatever whatever feel comes out does
whatever yeah we all just do 20 or
whatever and then after we all go on the
stage yeah we do the show and then and
then fans do live king you're stinging
it live
that's like double dancing been doing
that forever with his shows man doug
benson oh yeah doug benson he's got like
so many live shows that he does like
that that are associated with his
podcast should do the same thing man i
think we should do i think we should
take king and a sting on the road what
do you say to that let me write some
stuff let me write don't i have to hit
open mic so i don't want to just go and
cold don't i have to yes dude yeah i
have to start doing that yeah you'll be
fine
but you know and that's
two shows friday two shows saturday only
with the squad david lucas chappelle
lacy and myself friday saturday at brea
this [ __ ] friday saturday and
then uh november 11th through the 13th
is dallas addison improv that's a
special night for your boy come on out
dallas november 11th through the 13th
and you got your dates right up there
dog oh yeah
what's up daddy comedy on state in
wisconsin this weekend 14th through the
16th and i'm at the arlington uh draft
house that's a great room i got all that
stuff there too but come on out to
comedy i can't wait to i haven't been
there in a while so i'm looking forward
to going to wisconsin
on wisconsin yeah i'm from
youtube.com tell your friends
oh and then i'm getting we're getting
the band back together you know david
cho money mark so we're recording new
music so look out for we're gonna do a
reunion show
sometime and then
soon when once we get done recording
this new stuff love it man love you guys
thanks showing up deal we miss you deal
special drops what october what
go get it by go get i mean watch it love
you guys we're out
brennan and theo fighter and weight i
got to go in and go hard in the paint i
do not think i am in flow black rifle
coffee i'm ready to go i need a sponsor
i am a monster about to open up with
this at my concerts flow is contagious
browser outrageous thicker than girls
that are instagram famous damn hungry
like i'm fresh off keto seeing red like
andrew santino every song i hit like the
great bambino burning ain't the queso
and the quesoritos but everything's
gonna be fine
hate on me i do not mind
theo looking like the type of dude that
got a pack of matches in his pockets at
all times they sliding into my dms a
couple of you trapping couldn't beat
them quit playing like nintendo ds you
don't want to smoke like joey diaz
meaning y'all edible just got my
eyebrows threaded and i'm feeling
incredible brandon's son hit me up he
said it's too loud in the club can you
pick me up
[Music]
on
[Music]
the trap got the cheese on a string
[Music]
you